wir werden dich kleinen [ __ ] bald
abschlachten ich weiß ja wo du wohnst
der juden sei deshalb so unbeliebt weil
er ständig auf opfer macht aber
tatsächlich schlimmste täter seid ja
manche stehen vielleicht auf
psychopathen ich halte wir ihm die
daumen dass kommentare so genannte hate
speech
sie wird digital verbreitet in foren
kommentarspalten in sozialen netzwerken
und sie trifft meist marginalisierte
menschen frauen people of colour crew
ihre menschen personen mit behinderungen
dieser hass hat system und er bleibt oft
nicht im netz - diese ist ein trans mann
und buchhändler in berlin der
transgender aktivist bloggt über sein
leben und hat auch ein buch darüber
geschrieben
auf twitter folgen ihm über 22.000
menschen
ich habe mich danach sehr gut als ich
für die ersten kommentare bekommen habe
dass ich da wirklich irgendwie weint auf
dem bett weil ich so aus allen wolken
gefallen bin weil ich mich irgendwie so
über mein coming-out gefreut habe und
über die positiven rückmeldungen und
dann zum ersten mal festgestellt habe es
reagieren gar nicht alle positiv und es
ist irgendwie ja dann quasi stück für
stück schlimmer geworden dann im sommer
2009 10 war dann jemand im laden dann
hat mich gefilmt und das war dann so
irgendwie der moment für mich wo ich
dann auch tatsächlich angst bekommen
habe zur arbeit zu gehen und und wann da
hat es dann abends an der tür geklingelt
und stand dann jemand direkt vor meiner
wohnungstür und ich habe ihn dann durch
den türspion gesehen hatte halbe stunde
an meiner tür geklingelt und geklopft
ich habe dreimal bei der polizei
angerufen und die polizei ist nicht
gekommen - diese geht es vielen
betroffenen bei der polizei fielen
strukturen und bewusstsein anzeigen
laufen oft ins leere
viele betroffene bleiben mit der
situation allein - diese suchte sich
hilfe bei einer therapeutin die auf
online haas spezialisiert ist kurzzeitig
glaube ich bin nicht gefahr gelaufen
wirklich so eine angststörung einfach zu
haben weil ich angst hatte meine wohnung
zu verlassen
ich hatte angst nach hause zu kommen ich
hatte bei jeder person die sich
irgendwie komisch verhalten hatte habe
ich angst gehabt dass sie dazu gehört
oder mir etwas böses will
una großmann ist schon seit jahren
zielscheibe von überwiegend rechte maß
die jüdische autorin arbeitet in
gedenkstätten und museen und schreibt
über jüdisches leben und antisemitismus
da werde ich dann schon mal beschimpft
als deutsch hasserin so absurd es
welcher deutsche bin und dass mir werden
verschwörungen unterstellt und ich will
die nation zerstören also es geht immer
in diese richtung und ich soll
gefälligst verschwinden sonst machen das
andere für mich
das ziel dieses konzertierten hasses ist
es bestimmte stimmen einzuschüchtern und
zum schweigen zu bringen und es wirkt an
mir selbst merke ich dass twitter zum
beispiel für mich keine
diskursplattformen es ist nur noch so
einen soll ein angriff stone also es
gibt nur noch die und wir so die anderen
und wir und das war's nicht ist ja
gesellschaft auch mit nadine brömme
setzt sich schon lange mit dem haus
auseinander
vor vier jahren hat sie eine
vernetzungsstelle gegen hate speech mit
gegründet das netz soll die
zivilgesellschaft stärken um dem hass
etwas entgegenzusetzen
denn überwiegend wird dieser hass von
einer minderheit verbreitet die
systematisch vorgeht
eine studie zeigt dass bei hass
kommentaren fünf der beteiligten
accounts für 50 prozent der likes
verantwortlich sind
dadurch können meinungsbilder verzerrt
werden das nutzen laut studie vor allem
rechte accounts für ihre zwecke
das sind fast schon militärisch oder
hierarchisch organisierte strukturen
also wer mehr hass kommentare verbreitet
bekommt umso mehr anerkennung und die ja
diese gruppen die suchen sich opfer aus
also das wirklich eine armee von
rechtsextremen trollen auf
einzelpersonen los geht und es sind
organisierte hetzkampagnen und die ganz
krassen fälle also wie der mord an
walter lübke
der terroranschlag in hanau und in halle
zeigen ja dass aus online gewalt auch
physische gewalt wird und dass das ein
gesellschaftliches problem ist solche
systematischen schutz torrance hat auch
sibel schick schon abbekommen
die autorin und journalistin schreibt
über sexismus und rassismus auch ihre
wohnadresse wurde schon veröffentlicht
fremde menschen schickten ihre sendungen
sie wurde beschimpft und bedroht
unterstützung bekommt sie von angeles
und beratungsstellen wie hey tate doch
deren mittel sind begrenzt strukturen
die betroffenen akut helfen also ist
jemand betroffen wie können wir dieser
person helfen kann die person
beispielsweise heute nacht nicht zu
hause schlafen ok hoping mir diese
person unter siebel schick hat eine
petition gestartet die über 200.000
menschen unterzeichnet haben
darin fordert sie mehr opferschutz und
bessere strukturen zur bekämpfung der
online-kriminalität beispielsweise in
der polizeiarbeit bestehen hat große
lücken
sie werden nicht ausreichend ausgebildet
in dem bereich sie kennen sich nicht aus
mit rechtsextremen strukturen in den
sozialen netzwerken
sie nehmen die dimension des problems
gar nicht wahr die sie ist weil wir
haben halt wirklich mit einem
demokratieproblem zu tun gerade
am ende steht die öffentliche meinung
auf dem spiel denn wer bedroht und nicht
geschützt wird zieht sich aus dem
diskurs zurück das wird auch durch
studien belegt dass es auch wirklich
dazu führt dass menschen wirklich von
ihrem recht auf freie meinungsäusserung
keinen gebrauch machen können weil sie
so drastisch gewalt ausgesetzt werden
dass sie sich für ihre eigene sicherheit
oder für die sicherheit ihrer familien
ihre angehörigen zurückziehen müssen
das müssen wir wirklich als
rechtsverletzung einordnen wie sehr sich
viele einschüchtern lassen zeigt die
bisher größte befragung zu hass im netz
47 prozent der internet nutzenden geben
an sich in reaktion auf hate speech
seltener an diskussionen im netz zu
beteiligen
54 prozent bekennen sich seltener zu
ihrer politischen meinung viele momente
wo ich denke mal nehmen wir irgendwie
auch erfüllt wenn ich mich von twitter
abmelden würde aber irgendwie kann ich
es auch noch nicht nicht lassen weil ich
glaube dass es auch wichtig ist das also
dass eine stimme wie meine sich eben
nicht wegdrängen lässt sondern weiter
präsent bleibt aber ich suche mir quasi
etwas bewusster die kämpfer aus die ich
noch kämpfen möchte und lasse meinen sie
dinge einfach sein weil ich dafür keine
kraft habe